George Michael is a pimp who is all
about the ladies come on I Want Your Sex
I sound like he's singing to a guy
I'm gonna burn
[Music]
you I'm sorry we met we were when you
get around telling me your name
Oliver trinkets
[Music]
[Laughter]
terribly but with years of therapy I
thought I'd gotten past that however you
seem to have brought it all back up Miss
uh Mrs
[Music]
Mrs
wow not us seeking Revenge can lead to
the fires of hell you never heard
cussing until you've seen a 50 year old
Catholic woman stop by her daughter's
dorm and find her in bed with another
girl
Revenge never tastes Miramax
International presents
[Music]
Aflac just not use my brush start Ollie
every time when I'm comb my hair I spent
15 minutes taking these long bushy hairs
out of my
brushed Jennifer Lopez it is my birthday
they're just skinny because they're all
coked out holes
[Applause]
in the story of a man who wanted it all
had gotten more than he bargained for
[Music]
you
absolutely not but everybody in my class
has seen it everyone in your class has
morons with no taste for parents
[Music]
let me think
Jersey Girl
[Music]